finding an opening to any movie is
always a challenge because you're kind
of setting the table for the movie and
story to come
we had to remind the audience that
syndromes jet from the first film
destroyed their house this was
interesting because it said what
happened directly after that moment and
I imagined that they would have to
strategize on what they're gonna do they
don't have a house anymore they don't
have a phone this isn't a universe where
cellphones exist and they would have to
somehow get to a phone and halt dhikr to
come pick them up again
and I think it's funny it's kind of
scruffy and flabby because it's a
version that we didn't stay with very
long it is kind of fun and is
interesting in showing how we explore
these ideas I hate to cut short a tender
moment but unless you wanna explain this
to a crowd come on
[Applause]
this is your plan to hide in the bushes
of the Spratlys backyard I suppose you
think the cully's have better bushes and
no this is not my plan we need to get to
a phone right to call dicker well the
nearest pay phone is pay phone are we
what do you think we should do knock on
the neighbor's door wearing our super
suits and they notice I'm gone just say
I went to call dicker okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]